[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Applause]
for getting tricky guys I can't stay on
them for much longer
[Music]
they say an open road helps you think
about where you're going
where have you been
from the first night we met my heart
[Music]
for quarter mile at a time
the things change
[Music]
[Applause]
you drive just like your dad
no
nice afraid of losing someone
family is so impressive
[Applause]
please
made one mistake never thought my Man's
family the great Don Toretto
how do you choose the ones you save
us might not come back from this
everything that we've done none of it is
worth a thing if I lose you
if this is the finish line
I'm not afraid
[Music]
ride or die remember
promise
[Music]